so you you really think that the origin
of of life on Earth
is a really special event yeah if it did
originate on Earth my question for those
that search for life outside the Earth
is what if you had a letter from God and
the letter said
um life didn't originate on earth like
would you choose a different profession
like it would seemed hopeless like in
other words we only have a sample of one
in fact we only know of one conscious
life form let alone one planet that has
life on it right but what if you knew
for sure it didn't start here that means
that like there's almost nothing about
Earth that is
um originated it didn't originate the
life process so to study purely the
origin of life not life itself I think
that's still fascinating but how could
we learn about you know the origin of of
remember you have to go from inanimate
object to a living object whatever that
definition of life is and I'm not an
expert in many definitions Max Sarah you
know many different uh definitions but
but how do you actually go from from
inanimate to animate it's a huge
question yeah but then you don't have to
be the place where life originated to
replicate the origin or to under like uh
yeah that's one way to understand
something is to uh build it but another
way is to just observe it you don't have
to truly re-uh re-engineer from scratch
so I I you know I
but then yes if it didn't originate on
Earth then your intuition is about the
basic prerequisites of Life are are off
what's the governing principle right
like me what is uh and then you can have
just an almost an arbitrary number of
possible like if life didn't start on
Earth
foreign
because it's like we know even less than
we thought
the thing is it can prosper on Earth
though yeah so maybe the origin of life
is fundamentally different from the
maintenance of life right and maybe
maybe the existence of the earth life
symbiosis is critical I think Sarah and
you talked about Sarah Walker
um that it's a planetary phenomenon Etc
so doesn't that make it less like in
other words like not only do you need
special life conditions to create life
but then sustenance of life as you say
that also has to be maintained under
very specific circumstances by very
specific planets and with very specific
tectonic activity and moon and by the
way you need a Jupiter nearby you need
an earth and a moon system so that you
don't get bombarded too early and I
always think like this like
technological life I haven't said this
before really so I'm just speaking I
usually like to write down before I say
different things but one of the things I
thought about somebody hosts the podcast
you should probably accept the fact that
you're going to say stupid things every
once in a while not every once in a
while every while I claim that you know
to get to sending you know people to the
Moon you know our planet needed whales
and and dinosaurs right like you don't
make a solar panel from another solar
panel it you made a solar panel from a
factory that melted down glass silica
you know aluminum extruded that using
fossil fuels where do those fossil fuels
come from like so any civilization
that's going to be a Dyson you know
kardashev's uh did they have dinosaurs
like do they have like Prebiotic life do
they have a great oxygenation event did
they have a dimorphism between
prokaryotic eukaryote all those hurdles
they give each one let's say there's
eight hurdles and each one of those has
a probability of one in a thousand to go
from you know uh eukaryotic prokaryote
whatever let's say that's a one in a
thousand chats I think it's like one in
ten to the 40th or whatever if you
really do it but let's say first
generous nature one in ten to the three
let's say there's eight of those hurdles
that means you have you know 10 to the
to the uh to the 24th power uh different
uh possibility and that's just with
eight like the moon has to be there
Jupiter has to be there dinosaurs had to
be there all the different things that
we have to get the technological life
there's only 10 to the 20 only there's
10 to the 22nd we think Earth not earth
planets in the observable universe not
the Galaxy so that's a hundred times
fewer than the probability to get you
know 100 clearing these eight very low
hurdles of one in a thousand that's
fascinating because now I really need to
listen to your conversation with Lee
Cronin Club I believe you had because he
believes the opposite yes yeah I want to
have a debate with him he believes uh
that the the way biology evolved on
Earth could have evolved almost an
infinite number of other ways so like if
you ran Earth over and over and over you
would keep getting life and it would be
very different so it's the the fact that
our particular life seems unique is just
like well because every freaking life is
gonna seem unique but it'll be very
different it's not like we shouldn't be
asking the question of what's the
likelihood of getting a human-like thing
uh because that seems to be super
special it's more like
um how easy is it to make slime anything
that has the skills of a human and I
don't mean like something with thumbs
but achieving basically a technological
civilization and according to Lee at
least it's like it's it's trivial I know
we fought I fought a little bit I'd love
to debate him I think it'd be a lot of
fun because we debate with love when I
talk with Lee I love him and he loves me
I think I hope